and we're building a wall  in colorado  we're building a beautiful wall trump  floated the idea of swapping puerto rico  for greenland the ram that i descended  after my west point commencement speech  was very long and steep had no handrail  and most importantly was very slippery  our army manned the air  it ran  the ramparts it took over the airports  it did everything it had to do wherever  trump goes he tries to make himself seem  dominant over whoever he's shaking hands  with trump's strong looking situation  room photo was a staged photograph  likely taken hours after the event lock  them up you should lock them up  lock up the buttons lock up hillary i  too have a nuclear button but it is a  much bigger and more powerful one than  his the narcissist in chief donald trump  wanted his signature printed on all of  the checks